jonas geht hier ist euer max und wir
spielen heute ein ründchen pixel
painters mitarbeiter liebe nicht so ganz
liebe lud ja und geht s spitze also
pixel painters sich erklärt mal für euch
und auch für luca ist ein spiel muss
einfach das sozusagen paint und du
kannst damals ja oben einfach draufhauen
auf diese datei mit dem normalen willst
unten willst du die farben aus und
einmal zu und rechts die miss campbell
also kerze und das smart street gedrückt
halten und das malen was du brauchst wie
viel zeit ich habe drei minuten alten 14
es tut mir leid lud aber drei minuten 49
und einmal zu einfach nur ganz schöne
kerze und ich weiß nicht was schönes mal
deshalb habe ich dich hier eingeladen
ich weiß ja dass du deine alles mögliche
malen sehr freust du dich auf wales man
kann ein werkzeug nehmen bin fertig ist
schön mal lud mich dann gefragt
ja ich freue mich nutzen ich frage mich
ja und ich habe auch schon bald darauf
seinen eigenen test auf blut eine kerze
fertig
nein ich hab alles rückgängig gemacht
bist du echt fertig anfang noch mal neu
an zwei spraydosen natürlich du kannst
alles hier machen
ich habe gesagt das 1 1 funktionen wie
bei microsoft
wahrscheinlich gewinnst du dann trotzdem
so eine scheiße dass alle also danach
gibt es eine abstimmung für den gewinn
und trotzdem zufrieden damit was ich
gerade mal aber ich kann
ich kann nicht ich bin mit meiner kerze
sieht noch nicht du bist ja auch noch
nicht zufrieden mit
ich probiere es noch so lichtreflexionen
rein zu machen
ich bin echt scheiße im kunst leute
müssen wissen habe ich euch noch mal
gesagt was ich auch ne gute idee
ja ich werde jetzt echt schön malen
zumindest versuchen kann sein dass
nichts probieren denn es ist fertig
aber klar ich mache was die spitzen
effekte hin spitzen letzten machen
kannst ich bin echt zufrieden mit mir
soweit leute ist es nur eins erklärt sie
könne nicht sagen ob ein schönes nicht
aber ich bin gespannt auf die leute für
mich wollten werden muss es den leuten
jetzt klick und ihr freund waren die da
vorne
das mich raten welches von dir ist nicht
stimmt dann wird er da stimmt alter
unten rechts ist unglaublich gut
alter schwede manches klingt voll
dagegen
wie gut das können oder kann sein aber
treten unsere bilder gegeneinander an
den main ist immer noch nicht da unter
rechtlich schlagwort oben links
ja ich kann ich für mich selbst wurden
tut mir leid ich hab den schweren rechts
luca bitte auf den weg macht
niederschlag auf man hört jetzt gewonnen
was spitze luca ich hoffe auch für dich
nicht rausgeflogen ein gutes
nein ich bin weiter gekommen luca worte
für mich beim nächsten ok recht lustig
das gewinnt bestimmt und schlechtere
damit ich mal angeschossen hat ist
wirklich schlechter rechts gewinnt er
auch nicht ganz sein
ich bin deutlich weiter das ist richtig
sind alter schwede aber dahin will
vielleicht aber wird verabredet dazu gut
ein weltreich wc handy nicht grad schon
mal männer gewartet
ja ich verstehe auch nicht aber die
unentschieden waren glaube ich hält sein
wort gegeben
weitergekommen so westermann gewinnt
männerherzen bitte mit plus 7,87
okay das ist eine kette